the purpose of ebony alerts is to warn
people about black children actually
more than black children who have gone
missing Amber Alerts are designed to
alert people to any child who has gone
missing any child of any race you get an
alert on your phone we've all gotten
them then you look out and try to find
match the car or match the description
and a lot of children are found this way
California though has established ebony
alerts to prioritize searches for
missing black children so if a white
child and a black child go missing in
California they're going to say forget
about the white child the black child
that's the one you got to find first the
black child is much much more important
than the white child but it's even
crazier than that because the ebony
alerts don't
only warn you of of searches for missing
children it's also for young adults not
even all that young adults so for an
amber alert that the child has to be
under 17 for the ebony alert it's to
alert people to missing black persons
age 12 to 25